et comme chaque jeudi vous savez c'est
le moment de la chronique sport notre
journaliste sportif et mickaël millero
on sort michael alors quel est le thème
de votre chronique aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui je vous parlais du
rugby-club de versailles et plus
particulièrement de l'équipe senior en
fédérale 3 les joueurs de la cité royale
sont sortis de la zone de relégation
après une victoire contre vincennes sur
le score de 16 à 14 le week-end dernier
menés de 14 points au bout de dix
minutes de jeu les verse ayant su réagir
devant plus de 500 spectateurs
conséquence les bleus ne sont pas encore
enterré dans ce championnat on écoute la
réaction du président du club olivier
hahn air neufs est encore encore un
espoir la bête n'est pas complètement
morte
l'arrêt ne sont pas que ne s'est pas
encore véritablement en fait mais il
faudrait avoir le couteau entre les
dents pour pouvoir les jeux ea ou soeurs
et ça sera quand même très très très
compliqué une chance alors je vous
planter le décor floral ce soir la
dernière journée du championnat de
fédérale 3 auxerre a remporté 15 de ses
17 matches disputés cette saison les
bourguignons ont 10 points d'avancé sur
leur dauphin de l'autre côté nous avons
versailles avec trois petites victoires
cette saison et qui compte 53 points de
moins que versailles
vous l'aurez compris se sent un peu le
remake de david contre goliath
surtout que auxerre jouera à domicile
olivier 09 en a conscience c'est énorme
énorme avec un budget qui est de 705
150000 euros avec des trentenaires dans
la mêlée qui sont géorgiens roumains
italiens écossais et qui sont les rois
du groupé pénétrant ils ne sont que des
coups très pénétrants pour tout est un
des pénalités trop d touchera faire des
groupés pénétrants est allé jusqu'à
l'en-but donc c'est très compliqué quand
ton équipe jeune et qu'on a pas
dynamique c'est très compliqué là devant
leur public
il prend pas se permettre d'avoir le
moindre la moindre défaite donc que mon
avis ça va être très compliqué pour
renverser la montagne auxerroises les
verser en trois semaines pour se
préparer et soigner les pépins physiques
contre survenue contre vincennes le
coach baptiste gouache devrait compter
sur un groupe au complet les versailles
et vont jouer leur chance à fond
on a dit qu'on allait y aller le couteau
entre les dents on n'a pas fait tout
cette saison
avec des nuances très compliqué pour
essayer de tout lâcher
avant on est sur le terrain on nagera
mais à la fin on imagine que se
passera-t-il en cas de contre
performance on peut dire que c'est un
match qui était double pas forcément
florensis versailles perdre contre
auxerre et devront attendre le résultat
de pont-à-mousson et de vincennes pour
savoir si oui ou non ils descendront en
honneur versailles sera donc les scores
sur les téléphones ou sur les réseaux
sociaux en cas de descente
olivier nero 9 en est persuadé ses
joueurs ses protégés remonteront en
fédérale 3 dès la saison prochaine
j'ai aussi ce redoutable avantage d'être
depuis si longtemps dans ce club
50e année cette année consécutive donc
j'en ai fait des montent et descendent
en tant que joueur j'en ai fait aussi
les montées descentes en dirigeant on
est remonté en 2008 donc ça sera pas si
dramatique même je veux dire si la
concurrence est rude très compliqué en
honneur mais nous on a des jeunes on a
énormément de joueurs et je pense que
d'ici deux trois ans on aura notre
résurrection
le match est donc programmée le 24 avril
prochain sur le terrain d'auxerre on
leur souhaite évidemment de gagner ce
match et de se maintenir florennes on va
croiser les doigts pour eux le 24 avr et
les mains